fast decks made off with millions in his
opening weekend here's how the film
maintained the franchises box office
muscle 10 movies deep
longtime fans of the Fast and the
Furious franchise tend to make an event
out of the debut of each new chapter
first eggs is a 10th film in the main
series and 11th overall putting fast
movies in a rare class with long-running
franchises like Star Wars Star Trek the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and James Bond
though there might not be fast TV
tie-ins on the scale of Star Wars or the
MCU the series nevertheless is a loyal
and active fandom that has historically
shown up on opening weekend from 2009's
Fast and Furious onward the fast movies
have all ranked in at least 16 million
dollars domestically in the first
weekend of their theatrical run Liquid
Gold
2015's Furious 7 was the biggest of the
bunch banking nearly 150 million dollars
in its first three days every other
installment has come in respectably but
still under 100 million dollars stick to
the fast films of big opening weekends
went on to gross more than half a
billion dollars worldwide so things are
good for fast decks on the whole that
said two factors for a wrench into what
would otherwise be in qualified success
the 67.5 million dollars domestic take
for fast X is the second lowest since
Fast and Furious beating only the side
project Fast and Furious presents Hobson
Shore which debuted with about 60
million dollars the latest films 340
million dollar production budget also
far exceeds the rest of the franchise
which means fast decks will have to do
much better by the end of its run just
to break even
fast tags might not have led the
domestic box office on fire but its
International receives a smoking hot the
film's 318.9 million dollars Global
total is the second best of the year so
far behind the Super Mario Brothers
movie when taking the US figure out of
the equation it's the single best
International debut of 2023. worldwide
ticket sales are where the fast films
have managed to hold steady and even
make gains while sci-fi and superhero
franchises have struggled lately to
paint a better picture let's compare
fast X and Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania fastx grows more than 250 million
dollars internationally in its first
weekend while the third Ant-Man film
barely crossed 100 million dollars
fastex did particularly well in China
but it also performed admirably in Italy
and Brazil two countries that service
locations on the globetrotting action
film all right dorks what are we blowing
up what the Vatican more proof that
spectacle in this case spectacular car
chases physics defying stunts and epic
explosions is a universal language fast
eggs had a strong opening on iMac
screens the film made about 22 million
dollars from the more expensive ticket
sold for that format and the majority of
Imax ticket sales 16.2 million dollars
came from overseas
bustex benefited from the fact that it
hit theaters at the very beginning of
the summer movie season before the
Marquis got too crowded with big name
Blockbusters one reason for its 318.9
million dollar worldwide opening is
simply a lack of competition it's been
seven weeks since the Super Mario
Brothers movie had screens so the
majority of viewers who wanted to see
the video game adaptation have already
seen it Mario is also available to rent
or purchase via video on demand by now
which likely steered even more
moviegoers to fast X Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 has been holding its own at
the box office nearing the 700 million
dollar Mark in worldwide ticket sales
but it's two-week Head Start made some
room for whatever audience overlap there
is between Guardians 3 and fast X
elsewhere down the list is R-rated fare
such as Evil Dead rise which was in its
fifth week and John witch up to four in
its ninth there was also the warmer
fluffier book club the next chapter and
are you there God it's me Margaret had
fuss decks contended with the flash
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny or
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
1. it may not have conquered the box
office quite so handily
first movies have never been Prestige
Cinema even so about half of the entries
in the franchise have scored decently
well with critics with furious 7 and
Fast 5 coming in at the top it took a
while for critics to catch on to what
audience has already knew the early fast
films linked with the bottom of Rotten
Tomatoes ranking probably in part
because reviewers didn't have a sense of
what the over-the-top franchise was
trying to do many of the positive
comments pertaining to the later films
phrased them for self-awareness and
sheer fun unfortunately for fast X
though the critical Community is divided
even those who had good things to say
about the film are mostly muted in their
praise while those who disliked it
haven't held back with their complaints
critics have compared it to sustaining a
head injury referring to the script as
something that an eight-year-old could
have written others simply call it loud
and dumb butts that hasn't deterred fans
who took to Rotten Tomatoes and social
media sites where they have the films
back fastex currently has a 86 audience
score compared to its 54 critical Tomato
Meter rating viewers seem to appreciate
the plot twist as well as a Non-Stop
action and since the general public is
who's buying the tickets and the popcorn
especially for a deep into the franchise
movie like Fast Tax they're a better
predictor of a movie's bottom line
one thing that most critics and fans
agree on is that Jason Momoa is a
worthwhile addition to the Fast and the
Furious family from Vin Diesel and Jason
Statham to John Cena and Dwayne The Rock
Johnson the sprawling cast was already
pretty full up on middle-aged muscly men
the 43 year old Momoa who also plays
Aquaman is arguably a similar type of
actor they don't always get credit for
their craft and if we're being honest
fans don't really come to see their
movies for humanistic performances in
the first place and like with the dceu
the franchise itself is the brand name
like many of his cohorts Mamoa is a
well-like celebrity who audiences are
happy to see in movies but whether he
was a reliable box office draws with an
open question it's not necessarily Momoa
star power that convinced viewers to
come out for fast X more likely it was
the strong Buzz he earned for his
performance as a series newest villain
Dante Reyes the actor told variety that
he conceived of Reyes as an androgynous
vengeful peacock I'm Dante I'm Shantae
the son of the drug lord Slade in Fast 5
Reyes has a pre-delict for nail polish
and colorful cars well critics fans
amamoa himself acknowledge their
performances over the top the consensus
is that's a good thing Dante Reyes is an
entertaining president who steals the
movie also the rest of the cast is
stacked
well the Fast and the Furious films
feature more than their fair share of
stanza's action set pieces arguably only
a few of the 11 installments have risen
to the level of legitimately good
filmmaking 2011's Fast 5 and 2015's
Furious 7 are frequently cited as a
franchise's high points fast tax
director Louis letterier told
Entertainment Weekly that the fifth film
is easily the best and his 10th film is
essentially a direct Fast 5 sequel the
Terry a reframes him from a safe chase
by adding in the perspective of Dante
Reyes who has knocked off a bridge in
Rio while his father Hernan is killed
this becomes a motivation for momoa's
character who wants Justice for his
father's death and the loss of his
family's Fortune dipping back into past
narratives and even changing what the
audience has seen before is a tactic
that the Fast and the Furious series was
employed again and again often with
crowd-pleasing results since the world
was out the fast X had strong
connections to Fast 5 it's reasonable to
think some fans perhaps even some who
haven't kept up with the entire series
showed up to see how the 4 to the latter
even some of the fast franchises most
Arden supports has thought that the film
series may have finally jumped the shark
with F9 a movie in which among other
physics and logic defying Feats tej and
Roman enter actual space and a rocket
car man this is insane we are headed to
outer space you acting like me on our
way to Home Depot
what started as a standalone film about
street racing based on a real piece of
investigative journalism has become an
even more purposefully unbelievable
collage of cinematic stunts with each
subsequent sequel feeling the pressure
to up the ante fast X tone sings down
ever so slightly but we're still a long
way from good old-fashioned drag racing
in downtown Los Angeles and that's more
than okay with fans they've come to
expect ridiculous death-defying hijinks
that either wouldn't work in the first
place or would absolutely kill a human
being who wasn't wearing franchise plot
armor if it could be done in a car they
did it
it violates the laws of God and gravity
they did it twice yes fast X is more
kinetic energy than comprehensible plot
and yes there's some egregious
superiorification of the characters as
well as obvious fan service versus
anyone going to a fast and the furious
sequel this deep into the franchise
hoping for subtlety but we think not
even those who can't help but point out
are nonsensical the movie is also can't
stop themselves from enjoying it
if there's one thing people know about
the Fast and the Furious including
people who've never seen a single film
in the series it's that even more than
they are about cars these movies are
about family I don't have friends
I got family for an end joke to work
itself into the culture so thoroughly
that practically everyone gets it the
fast franchise must be doing something
right fast X not only utters the world
more times than viewers can count but it
also makes good an essential theme
exploring the bonds between Fathers and
Sons especially the terretto family tree
is pretty twisty and branchy and the
legion says turn on a dime whenever the
plot requires it for a franchise that's
been going strong for over two decades
it's become a necessary path to the
design one way to think of the fast
movies is as a gritty testosterone
fueled big budget soap opera fans that
have stuck with this series follow their
favorite characters and try to guess who
will backstab or make amends with who
for all the slingshotted cars and races
against trains these movies do have a
human element to them and one that's
surprisingly Earnest particularly when
compared to other hyper masculine
high-octane action movies maybe Without
fire and metal gives audiences a cover
they need to enjoy what's really just a
sappy story at heart
the biggest box office successes of all
time the fast films among them almost
all have something in common they're
rated PG-13 the PG-13 rating stretches
from the later installments on the Harry
Potter franchise to the most recent
Guardians of the Galaxy movie which
features the mcu's first ever F-bomb
it's not exactly an informative measure
of a film's family friendliness but
generally speaking it affords families
at least those of slightly older
children the ability to take everyone to
the movie theater for the night but that
typically gives an automatic boost to
PG-13 titles teens and adults won't
always seek out G or PG films on their
own or younger audiences are prohibited
for movies that receive in our rating
fast eggs and its PG-13 rating full
squarely in line with other broadly
appealing box office behemoths like
Avatar Titanic Star Wars Jurassic Park
and last year's big hit Top Gun Maverick
in a cultural atmosphere where identity
politics can quickly derail the film's
Mass Appeal fast X manages to remain
uncontroversial that helps performance
at home where admittedly the franchise
has been stalling out a bit and has
certainly helped abroad where big budget
films have to play ball with some
country's conservative census
[Music]